so today uh we will jump into the goals
of the course and the logistics of the
course and also talk a little bit about
what multitask and metal learning is and
why we might want to study it
uh before we get started I want to make
some introductions so my name is Chelsea
I'm the main instructor for the course
and we also have seven really awesome
Tas
um great so I'd love to welcome you to
the course uh and I guess as a first
question to get a sense
everyone's at uh how are you doing if
you want to answer
briefly do you want to raise your hand
and share how things are going
yeah but my first class I went to the
wrong class
it's always interesting how like five
minutes three to class I saw the title I
see public policy when I was supposed to
use AI great great well I'm glad you
made it to the right class this time
anyone else
four plus
cool cool good to figure everything out
anyone else
okay well
um I guess one thing I wanted to share
or say is that I it's feels great to be
closer to something that's a little bit
more normal
um and that's yeah it's really awesome
I'm really excited about that at the
same time it's not like uh every it's
like like there's lots of other stuff
going on in the world right now that's
um not great and so we acknowledge that
and we
um we've tried to set course policies
that make give you a little bit of
flexibility in the course and
um yeah recognize that this course isn't
the only thing going on in your lives
and so
um hopefully those policies will help
with that
um great so we have a lot of information
and resources uh about the course uh
your first place to go is the course
website uh we put a lot of information
here so please read through it uh and if
you have any questions make sure that
you read through it first but then feel
free to post any questions that you have
on Ed Ed is connected to Canvas and you
can also reach out to the staff mailing
list as well we encourage you to post
any questions that you have to add
because that makes it so that other
students can see your questions because
other people probably have the same
question as you but you are allowed to
make a private post on Ed or email the
staff mailing list in cases where you
don't want it to be shared with others
in the class for example if you have an
oae letter you can send this either to
the staff mailing list or in a private
Ed post
um we also have office hours that are
all posted on the course website
um and the zoom links are on canvas and
office hours will start on Wednesday
uh cool so what will you learn in this
course
um there's really three main things that
we're going to hope you'll be able to
learn in this course the first is the
foundations of modern deep learning
methods for multitask learning and
generally learning across tasks
the second is not just learning about
those methods but actually getting
experience implementing them and working
with them uh in code in pytorch and
trying to understand how these systems
actually work in practice Beyond just
how they are supposed to work from
lectures
and lastly I also want to try to give
you a glimpse of the process behind
actually building these kinds of methods
I think that a lot of courses will
present you knowledge and present you
ideas as they are and not actually talk
a little bit about the scientific
process and the engineering process of
arriving upon those ideas and I'm hoping
that maybe by giving a little bit of a
glimpse into the process of building
these algorithms and understanding these
algorithms that will encourage you to
not take them as them is to challenge
them and also to help you learn about
the process of developing these kinds of
algorithms in the first place
cool um so along those lines uh we'll
cover a wide range of topics in the
course
um we'll start with kind of the basics
of multitask learning and transfer
learning we'll move into three broad
classes of meta learning algorithms
including Black Box approaches
optimization based approaches and Metric
learning
we'll also cover more advanced metal
learning topics such as overfitting and
meta learning unsupervised meta learning
and Bayesian metal learning methods
before moving into other approaches for
few shot learning and adaptation
including unsupervised pre-training and
domain adaptation and domain
generalization
um
all throughout this will be an emphasis
on deep learning techniques uh and we'll
also study a number of different case
studies in real applications uh this
includes things like multitask learning
and recommender systems like the
recommendation system behind YouTube
also meta learning for land cover
classification and education as well as
few shot learning in large language
models
now uh one thing that's a little bit
different from the last time we offered
this course is uh these topics right
here are all new to the course
and one thing that's different is we're
not going to have any lectures or
homeworks that cover reinforcement
learning topics
um and so essentially we're removing the
reinforcement learning topics from the
previous quarters and adding in this new
content including a few shot learning
with unsupervised pre-training
um how this relates to Foundation models
as well as domain adaptation and domain
generalization
now you might ask why are we removing
the reinforcement money content what if
I want to work on reinforcement learning
um for that we're introducing a new
course in the Spring quarter on deep
reinforcement learning that I think will
do a nice job of complementing some of
the other reinforcement learning
offerings on campus
removing reinforcement learning will
also make the course more accessible to
people who don't have a lot of
background in reinforcement learning we
found that in the previous quarters just
one kind of refresher on reinforcement
learning often wasn't enough to get to
the more advanced topics
um that said if you're really excited
about applying some of the ideas in the
course to reinforcement learning topics
you can still explore that in the final
project and get support from the core
staff many of whom also are very
familiar and experts in reinforcement
learning problems
awesome
um so for lectures uh all the lectures
are in person they're also live streamed
and recorded and you'll have access to
the recordings on canvas
we're also going to have two guest
lectures as well around the the end of
the quarter and those are not fully
sorted out yet but we'll announce those
shortly
I really encourage you to ask questions
during the lecture this serves a lot of
different purposes you can ask questions
by raising your hand you can also ask
them by entering questions in the zoom
chat and we have a TA who will monitor
the chat and make sure those questions
get answered during the lecture
um I find it really helpful when people
ask questions because it helps me
understand engage if you're
understanding what I'm saying and if you
don't understand something some concept
or want to learn more or I'm not
covering something important uh that's
my fault that's not your fault and
chances are other people have the same
sort of misunderstanding and so if you
ask that question that will help
everyone in the course and help me help
you basically my goal is to help you
learn the topics in the course rather
than standing up and listening to myself
speak
uh office hours will have a mix of
in-person and remote
um mostly in person but there will be
two remote options especially for scpd
students who are in the course
great um and then I'll prerequisites uh
the main prerequisite is to have
sufficient background in machine
learning so something like cs229 or
equivalent because we'll be building a
lot on the basic concepts of machine
learning and we're not going to kind of
cover topics like cross-validation
training sets and test sets and so forth
were the basics of neural networks
um all the assignments are going to
require training neural networks in
pytorch if you really hate pytorch for
whatever reason you could implement the
assignments in some other framework
but all the starter code is in pytorch
and you'll be able to get more support
if you do everything in pytorch so we'd
encourage you to do it in pytorch a few
quarters ago
the course use tensorflow instead and
people seem to really like to switch to
pytorch
um but hopefully uh yeah we provide some
flexibility there
we're also going to have a pytorch
review session on Thursday at 4 30 PM in
this room and so if you want a refresher
or some get some of the kind of Concepts
in pytorch that will be useful for the
assignments you can come to that review
session it will also be live streamed
and recorded on Zoom as well
cool
um so digging it in a little bit more
into the content will have
a number of different assignments the
first assignment is just going over it's
basically just a warm-up to make sure
you're familiar with pytorch and going
over some of the basics in multitask
learning
um then we'll start to go into our core
assignments the first one will be on
Black Box metal learning and how do you
set up the data to make few shot
learning with these block box models
more effective
the second we'll go into gradient-based
metal learning and Metric learning
both these assignments will include kind
of few shot character recognition kinds
of problems
and then the third homework will go into
fine-tuning pre-trained models with an
emphasis on uh natural language
processing and language models rather
than image recognition
and then the last homework
um is going to be optional and it's
going to cover some more conceptual
aspects of the course so the first four
homeworks are all going to be
implementation based whereas this last
homework will be just kind of so
paper
the grading for the course is 50
homework 50 project uh the first
homework is just a warm up so it's only
five percent of the grade whereas the
remaining three the next three homeworks
are each 15 of the grade so this adds up
to fifty percent
um I mentioned that we wanted to provide
some flexibility to students in the
course and so if you complete this
fourth homework it can be used to
replace one of the previous homeworks or
it can be used to replace part of the
project grade and if you do it we'll
we'll always do whatever is best for
your grade and so you don't if you don't
do well on that homework but you still
try to complete it then it won't hurt
your grade it will only help
um and then the second aspect of giving
some flexibilities will give six late
days across homeworks and project
related assignments um you can use up to
two late days per assignment
um no questions asked anyone can use
these
um up to the six of course if you have
other extenuating circumstances that
make it difficult to submit courses on
time then feel free to send us a note
send us an email and we may be able to
make accommodations Beyond these six
late days
um great and then lastly uh for the
collaboration policy please read the
course website and the honor code for
the homeworks you're allowed to talk to
other people about the homeworks but you
should document your collaborators and
please write up the homework solutions
on your own without referring to other
student Solutions and without referring
to Solutions on the internet
cool um for the final project this is
the basically the main parts of the
course are in terms of your work or the
assignments in the project the project
is a research level project of your
choice that you can do in groups of one
to three
um if applicable if you're doing
research on campus we really encourage
you to use your research for this
project
um and as long as it's applicable to the
topics that are covered in the course
and you can also share the project with
other courses although we'll have
slightly higher expectations in that
case
uh and then same late day policy as the
homeworks
um but there's no late days for the
poster session because the poster
session will be alive
um event and you can't uh there won't be
a late poster session or anything like
that
and the poster presentation the poster
session is on December 7th which is
basically the last day of classes which
will happen instead of a lecture
cool um so any questions on course
um Logistics
yeah what type of topics can we work on
for a final project
um yeah so I mean basically the question
is what kind of topics can you work on
for the final project
basically whatever you want as long as
it pertains to the course content
um it's very open-ended I guess one
other thing that I can mention there is
that we're going to have we are
soliciting ideas from the broader
Stanford AI community and so we'll post
a list of ideas for the project on
Monday next week and so if you're not
sure what kind of project you want to do
you can look at that list for some some
nice ideas but if you have something in
mind already or if you um if you want to
be creative and think of something else
it just needs to pertain to the the
topics of the course
we also have detailed guidelines on the
project and what we expect posted on the
course website and so you can refer to
that document
um for a lot more details
examples of what people have done in the
past
yeah that's a great question so we
haven't posted examples yet but we want
to post some examples of of some
previous projects one thing that you can
see already is that if you
um if you look at a previous offering of
the course I think it was two years ago
we posted titles of all the court of all
the course projects and then some of
them have links from students who are
willing to to make them public and so
you could already take a look at that
although we're planning to provide some
more explicit examples in the coming
week
cool
um so in terms of initial steps uh
homework zero has already been posted
this should be pretty lightweight uh
it's due in a week all the assignments
are due at 11 59 Pacific time
um and I'd encourage you to start trying
to form groups uh if you want to work in
a group and posting making posts on Ed
and so forth can be helpful for that
um and we're also like
um happy to try to help you connect with
other students in the course as well if
that would be helpful
[Music]
right here
yeah I think that there can be pros and
cons to working in a group uh the I
think that the benefit is that there's
there's a little bit more that you can
do in a group and uh you might also have
complimentary expertise it can also be
fun to work with other people
um the downside is that you are kind of
relying on other people a little bit and
um you want to kind of make sure that
the people you're working with are
you're kind of compatible and can rely
on them to some degree
um generally we recommend it uh but it's
certainly not required and um
and you're welcome to to work alone
cool so let's dive into uh why we might
want to study multitask learning and
metal learning
so
um the first thing I'll cover here is a
little bit of my perspective and why I
find multitask learning and metal
learning really cool and exciting
uh and in particular a lot of the
research that I do in my lab is trying
to think about this question of how we
can allow agents to learn a breadth of
different skills in the real world
uh and what I mean by agents is actually
working with real robots uh and allowing
them to learn skills like this so here
I'm holding the the Block in front of
the robot and it's learning to to place
the red block into the shape sorting
Cube
but not just something like that being
able to do something like watching a
video of a human place an object into a
bowl and having the robot figure out how
to do the task as well
um or by figuring out how to use tools
to complete a task even if it's not
explicitly told that it should use that
tool to complete the task
um and I think that robots are really
cool and interesting because I I think
that they can teach us things about
intelligence uh they are faced with the
real world they aren't just
um
they aren't just kind of looking at
images and in a static
we actually have to have to contend with
the complexity of the real world in
order to be useful in a in the real
world they have to generalize across
lots of different tasks objects and
environments
and I think they also need some sort of
Common Sense understanding they need to
understand what will happen if they try
to pick up objects or try to move their
arm in a certain way
uh and then the last thing is it's not
it's not clear exactly what the
supervision should be here as well
um and I guess Beyond these two things
beyond beyond trying to teach us things
about intelligence is also that there's
also this aspect that uh if if we can't
actually build robots that are very
useful then they can help out in a wide
range of aspects of society
um where people are doing jobs that are
dangerous or people that are people are
doing jobs that are tedious um or jobs
that they would rather not be in
and so
I guess from that standpoint I would
like to tell a little bit of a story
which is that at the beginning of my PhD
I was a PhD student on the other side of
the bay and I was working with this
robot right here
and this is a project that was happening
the robot was learning through trial and
error it was trying to figure out how to
insert the wheels of this toy airplane
into uh the corresponding hole
and what you can see is that at the very
beginning it didn't really know anything
about the task and over time it gets
better and better at trying to figure
out how to kind of assemble this part
into the plane
uh this seems pretty cool uh
it yeah I found it like really really
cool to see this whole process but one
caveat here is that the robot
effectively had its eyes closed
so the robot couldn't actually see
anything it wasn't using the camera in
any way it was just using the position
of of the joints
and so the next step that I really
wanted to explore in in a follow-up
project was to think about can we allow
the robot to complete these kinds of
tasks but with its eyes open uh and
actually use Vision in order to solve
these tasks
um and this was uh the resulting project
and here we were trying to learn a
neural network policy that maps from
images taken from the robot's camera
directly to torque supplied at the
robot's joints
and you can see that over time it uh
is getting better at the task
um at the beginning it was just moving
his arm around pretty randomly and it
gets closer and closer to inserting the
block into the red hole and not only can
It insert the Block in the red hole for
one position of the cube but it can do
it for multiple different positions of
the cube and this is why it needs uh
Vision in order to succeed
um so this is pretty cool um this was I
mean these days this maybe isn't that
impressive but uh six years ago no one
had really ever applied neural networks
for this kind of task before
and um here's actually kind of the
results of the final policy so you can
actually see the robot's perspective
right here and we can see that like if I
held it in different positions the robot
was able to insert the block into the
correct place
um this is pretty cool now
I think what was exciting about this
wasn't that the robot had figured out
how to do this one particular task
but rather that we had a reinforcement
learning algorithm that could allow
robots to do lots of different tasks and
so if you took the same exact algorithm
and gave it a different reward function
then it could figure out how to do other
tasks so it could figure out how to
place the claw of the toy hammer
underneath the nail
or if you gave it a task um right here
it could figure out how to screw a cap
onto a bottle
and an example of one more task this was
in a follow-up work we got the robot to
use a spatula to lift an object into a
bowl this last task is actually
surprisingly challenging because the
robot has to fairly aggressively
maneuver the spatula underneath the
object in order to lift it up
um so this is this was really exciting
This was um like first or second year of
my PhD um that we got the robot to do
these kinds of tasks all with um
learning neural network policies
and other people use the same kind of
algorithm and built up on it extended it
to other tasks into other robots to
learn things like hitting a Pucket into
a goal like opening a door and like
throwing an object to hit a Target
and around the same time people were
also using deep reinforcement learning
algorithms to play Atari games and to
play the game of Go and to learn how to
walk in simulation
so in general around kind of 2016 2017
was a very exciting time for
reinforcement learning and for deep
learning
um the catch though is that
we have a bit of a problem here in
general so it was all very exciting
progress but
there was this problem that in each of
these cases
when we train the robot to do a task
like when we trained it to lift the
object into the bowl
we didn't train it to use spatulas
generally and how to lift objects into
bowls but we trained it to lift that
particular object with that particular
spatula into that bowl
and so if you gave the robot a different
spatula put it in a different
environment
the robot wouldn't successfully complete
the task
and this is a huge problem because it
means that if we actually want to put
the robot into real world situations it
hasn't learned something that will
actually work in general
um
and you might say that okay maybe we can
just give the robot a lot more spatulas
and train it with
um with more data
but the tricky part is that when you
train these systems behind the scenes if
you actually look at the learning
process often it looks something like
this
where the robot attempts the task
uh and then
it needs these attempt the task again
and so for it to tempt the toss again
you need to actually kind of put put the
environment back to where it was and so
that they can attempt the task again
from that state
um in this video uh this is my friend
yevgen uh and
one of the things you probably noticed
here is that yevgen is doing more work
than the robot is doing
and this doesn't seem like
maybe the right way to be going about
things
um it importantly doesn't seem very
scalable
it's not practical to collect a ton of
data in this fashion
and so
this is
starting to get into why multitask
learning and Better Learning matters
which is that
um
we're training these systems to do one
very narrow thing and
this very narrow thing requires detailed
supervision a lot of extensive human
effort in order to get that system to do
that one particular thing and then if we
want to do something else we also need
another again a lot of human effort to
train from scratch on that new thing
um this isn't just a problem with
reinforcement learning and Robotics and
so if you look at problems in um kind of
speech recognition or object detection
um these systems are these systems are
trained on more diverse data
but they're still learning one task
starting from scratch with a lot of
supervision and Engineering for that one
task
and so I'd refer to all these systems as
kind of Specialists we're training a
machine Learning System to do one thing
and what in many cases would be more
useful is systems that are not trained
on a single task but on many different
tasks
um and so for example if we look at what
people can do people aren't trained from
day one to lift up spatulas uh or sorry
use use spatulations to lift up objects
but they're trained to learn much more
broadly about things in the world
um and in that sense I would refer to
humans as generalists um I'm interested
in this question of how we can build
machine learning systems that are more
General
um and I guess as maybe one more note on
this um if you take a system like
alphago which is became kind of champion
at the the game of Go
um
this is another example of kind of a
specialist system and uh if maybe
someone analogous to training a baby on
day one to try to figure out how to play
go without teaching them lots of other
things about the world
uh and in fact it turns out that
um even like training a training a robot
to pick up go pieces and place them into
the configuration is actually still
beyond the capabilities of uh
of AI systems and so when you watch
maybe if you ever watched any of the
alphago matches you'll notice that
um the alphago player is a human who's
just watching this computer screen and
lifting the pieces uh for the system
cool um so that's my perspective in
terms of
why I'm excited about these algorithms
um I guess any questions on all that
before I move on to things Beyond robots
and general purpose machine learning
I might go into this question and make
the next section but the question has to
do with um all of the work that's
happening on these large pre-trained
models now especially in NLP where maybe
the models are kind of implicitly
learning a lot of tasks internally so
um would you say that it's still
important to kind of explicitly teach
and model how to like encode a bunch of
these different Pastor can be implicit
learning kind of get us to moving to
people
yeah so the question is about
um like a lot of these large pre-trained
models are trained on very broad data
sets and they aren't explicitly trained
to do multiple tasks but they're
implicitly trained to learn very broad
things and
in some ways I would
um I guess we'll get we'll talk about
this a little bit later in the course
but I
um there are ways to connect that to
multitask learning and I I kind of view
that as an example of something that's
more of a generalist rather than
something that's learning one very
narrow task
um and so what we'll definitely connect
to that and I think that also gets to
some of the motivation behind using
generalists trying to train generalist
systems as well which is that if we can
train a pre-trained model on very broad
data and have it learn something more
General about the world then if we want
it to do something narrow after that we
can use that as initialization we don't
have to start from scratch we can start
from this more General understanding of
the world and use that as initialization
to learn much more quickly for a new
task and so some of the two the two of
the lectures that we're adding this year
will be precisely on training these
pre-trained models
um in a more General way with
unsupervised pre-training and then
fine-tuning them to with a small amount
of data to a new task
yeah so the question was um a lot of
kind of General NLP pre-training tasks
are things like fill in the blank um is
there an analog in something like
robotics
and uh in general I mean there are some
things that are somewhat analog so you
can take video data from the robot's
experience and have it interpolate
frames like say predict this Frame or
you can mask out part of an image and
say predict where um
basically fill in this this part of the
image and so you can make very direct
analogs like that and the approaches
like that have shown
some success in robotics although
um
there's there are also other aspects of
Robotics that make it very challenging
for example in NLP we have all of
Wikipedia and we don't have Wikipedia
for robotics we don't have data of
robots tying their shoes or robots
learning how to pour water it's just
lying on the internet in massive
quantities and that's
um that brings up another challenge
that's
um that is more readily solved in NLP
yeah
like this multitasking learning or or I
call this uh what it has a single task
and I give us this single task to learn
yeah I'll get to that
um at the very end of the lecture
cool so
um why should we care about multitask
learning and Better Learning Beyond
Robotics and general purpose machine
Learning Systems um and specifically why
should we care about deep learning in
this context
so um
I don't think deep learning needs too
much motivation these days uh if you've
taken a machine learning class but
um in terms of a couple slides
historically the approach to things like
computer vision was
to design some features uh to try to
design mid-level features and then try
to kind of train a classifier on top of
those mid level features and there are
many aspects of this kind of pipeline
that were designed by hand
um and then the more modern approach to
computer vision isn't to try to hand
design low level features and mid-level
features and so forth but rather to try
to just train a single neural network
end to end train the parameters end to
end to do the entire task
and um there are some benefits to the
former approach you get some some notion
of interpretability for example
but
um in general the second approach here
uh works a lot better which we'll see on
the next slide and it allows us to
handle unstructured inputs things like
pixels things like language sensor
readings uh really any input that you
could imagine without having to
understand without having to engineer
like really good features for that
particular domain
um so it allows us to perform tasks
without a lot of domain knowledge and as
we saw over the years on The imagenet
Benchmark this is showing uh performance
or error rate on the image that
Benchmark between the years 2011 and
2016.
um overall we see a downward Trend but
what's notable here is that
um this dot right here is Alex set which
was the first end-to-end approach for
the imagenet competition and everything
after that is uh is also deep learning
based approaches
um and so we saw this this really
striking Paradigm Shift uh and also very
striking shift in the performance that
you can get on these kinds of computer
vision tasks
um in a completely different domain in
natural language processing
um if we take uh this is a paper from I
think 2016 or 2017
um they're trying to use deep learning
for machine translation before this
paper Google translate was using
um something that wasn't doing
end-to-end deep learning it was called
the phrase based system and
um so that's called pbmt um whereas gnmt
was standing for Google's neural machine
translation which is an end-to-end
approach and we again see
um really large improvements
um like 60 to 87 Improvement on these
different translation tasks and now
systems like Google translate use
exactly these kinds of models when
making predictions and they work uh well
there's still obviously lots of room for
improvement in the translations but they
work far better than the previous
systems
um cool so that was some brief
motivation for why why we might focus on
deep Learning Systems now why might we
focus on deep multitasking meta learning
systems
so
in deep learning we've seen that if we
have a large and diverse data set and a
large model that leads to good
generalization on the tasks that I
showed on the previous slide
we saw this with imagenet with things
like Transformers machine translation
but there's a lot of scenarios where you
don't have a large and diverse data set
at the outset
there's scenarios like Medical Imaging
where you there are privacy concerns
with sharing lots of data or robotics
where we don't have Wikipedia for
robotics or things like personalized
education or translation for rare
languages
where we don't have a large data set
already sitting on the internet and it
would be very expensive and costly to
try to collect a large data set
and so these are the scenarios where
um
where this kind of recipe will start to
break down
and it's impractical to learn from
scratch for each of these
um for each of these different
circumstances like for each rare disease
or for each robot or for each person or
each language
now beyond that there's also scenarios
where maybe you have a large data set
but that data set is very skewed so you
have a long tail distribution
where this is showing kind of a
histogram of the number of data points
for different aspects or different parts
of your distribution different slices of
your distribution and these different
slices could correspond to objects that
the system has encountered or
interactions with different people
or the words that it has heard
um or driving scenarios and so on and so
forth
and these kinds of data sets don't arise
in a lot of machine learning Benchmark
problems but they actually come up all
the time in real world applications
there's a lot of words for example that
you hear all the time and a very very
long tail of words that come up much
less frequently and this long tail of
edge cases actually presents a major
problem for modern machine learning
systems and I would argue that's why we
don't have self-driving cars on the road
today because there's so many edge cases
that come up in in self-driving
situations
and
multitask learning and metal learning
won't solve this problem in and of
itself but there is some signs of life
that kind of indicate that if you can
leverage some priors from the big data
and try to translate that to the tale of
of situations then you might be able to
better handle these kinds of
distributions
um
cool
um beyond that uh
what if um
what if you want your system to quickly
learn something new uh this is again a
scenario where you don't have a lot of
data because you want to learn very
quickly you want to learn something very
quickly about a new person like a new
user or about a new environment like a
new environment that you've placed your
system into
um and for this I'd like to actually
give you guys a little test
um where I want you guys to learn
something new so
in particular um for this test I'm going
to give you a training data set
uh the training data set is the six
images on the left
and the far left images are all
paintings painted by Brock and the next
three columns are paintings painted by
Cezanne
and so your goal is to learn a binary
classifier between uh paintings by Brock
and painting spices on
um so I'll let you
train a little bit your classifier
um and now that you've hopefully learned
a decent classifier
um your goal is to classify this test
data point
and so raise your hand if you think this
is by by Brock
okay and raise your hand if you think
the device is on
Okay cool so
um most people got it right so this is
indeed by Brock
um and I tried to give you a little bit
of time to to train your classifier but
maybe some of you didn't converge
and you can see this
into the styles of the edges here for
example
um I picked this example not to be one
that's a little bit harder maybe closer
to the decision boundary
um
and yeah so this is an example of few
shot learning and so you took a really
tiny training data set with six data
points and we're able to generalize to a
new data point
um so how are you able to do that so
um if you were to train a machine
Learning System from scratch like a
convolutional neural network on those
data points from scratch it probably
wouldn't have gotten the right answer
like many of you did
um but the way that it was able to do
that or the way that you guys were
probably able to do that is
while you may not have seen these
paintings before or maybe even paintings
by these painters
you've learned how to see you you've
learned
um
how to recognize patterns and images how
to recognize paintings and all of your
previous experience allows you to learn
new tasks with small amounts of data you
weren't starting from scratch on this
problem
um and so this is what's called few shot
learning where your training data set
has a few data points it's small
um
and if you start learning is something
that you should be able to achieve if
you leverage prior experience rather
than starting from scratch
cool um so each of these four things
that we went over if you have um you
want a more general purpose system you
don't have a large data set you have a
long tail or you want to learn something
new all of these are scenarios where
ideas from multitask learning and meta
learning might be useful
um and and where these elements can come
into play
um so now Beyond why we should study it
there's a question of why we should
study it now
and in particular if you take some
papers from the 90s uh maybe
I think probably everyone was born by
the by 97. um but if you take some
papers by the late 90s uh maybe not is
anyone born before 97 or sorry after 97
oh wow
I'm getting a little old here
um
cool well if you take a paper before
most of you were born
um
it says things like
um we can try to train tasks in parallel
using a shared representation or
um
we can try to do multitask inductive
transfer adding extra tasks to a back
propagation Network so they're already
doing
deep multitask learning in this paper
you can take a paper from 98
um talking about few shot learning so
the ability to generalize correctly from
a single training example when faced
with the new things to learn humans can
usually exploit an enormous amount of
training data and experiences that stem
from other related learning tasks
um or uh
from even earlier from 1992 uh some
folks like Sammy bengio and Joshua
bengio who you may have heard of were
talking about the possibility of a
learning rule to learn to solve new
tasks um so ideas from metal learning
um so a lot of these ideas aren't that
new uh they've existed for a pretty long
time at this point
um
and yet even though they've existed for
a long time they're continuing to play a
major role in AI systems
question uh does meta learning also help
model generalization you have a large
data set
so does metal learning help
generalization even when you have a
large data set so
in general these methods will give you
the most bang for your buck if you have
a small data set
um because that's where leveraging
previous experience will be the most
useful if you have a really massive data
set then you will probably do pretty
well just training from scratch on that
data set
um it's possible that it some prior
knowledge might come in handy if you
have some distribution shift basically
if you have a large data set but your
test set is actually from a slightly
different distribution then you might be
able to learn in variances from your
previous data in a way that allow you to
do better even when you have a large
data set but in general if you have a
standard IID problem and you have a
large data set then things like prior
experience will be much less useful
cool um so now what are some examples of
actually looking at these kinds of
systems in uh
deepmind they were training a system to
do lots of different kinds of vision and
language tasks and they found that they
could actually train a single model that
could do something like object
recognition where
um in this example they describe a
chinchilla then they describe a Shiva
and then they give it an image of a new
animal and is able to recognize that
that new animal is an image of a
flamingo and also describe where the the
flamingo is found
um so I can do object recognition and
the same exact model can also do things
like reading um so you can give it a few
examples of images of numbers like
arithmetic problems 2.2 plus one uh five
plus six and so forth and then if you
give it a new image of in this case
three times six it's able to both read
the numbers and also complete the
arithmetic problem
and again the same model can also do yet
another task in this case it's trying to
count animals and so here it's given an
image of a few pandas and it's told that
this corresponds to Three Pandas and
um at the end is given an image of
several four drafts and it's able to
count the number of drafts and identify
that they're drafts
so
really cool about this system is that
it's it's not just specialized for one
thing it can do lots of different things
and it can do lots of different things
in a few shot way so
um you're giving it a few examples of
how you want to perform the task and is
able to leverage that in order to figure
out what you want it to do and
ultimately do that task
um so this is a one modern example
um that was pretty exciting one other
modern example is a paper that I
co-authored in 2021 that I personally
was very excited about where we were
using meta learning in an education
application
we're looking at trying to provide
feedback to students
um on work that they did open-ended
student work in a intro CS course
and so in particular the code in place
course was a really massive online
course that was offered by a few Folks
at Stanford
and
at the end of the course uh
there were 16 000 solutions that
students wrote up to the course and
grading 16 000 giving feedback and
Grading 16 000 Solutions is a massive
undertaking
and we were able to get volunteers to
give feedback on around a thousand of
the student programs
but if you train on those 1000 programs
from scratch
uh you're not able to get a very good
system because a thousand programs from
scratch these are python programs
um that we're trying to get feedback on
that doesn't work very well
but with Better Learning we were able to
train on previous data previous student
data of taking exams and giving feedback
on those exams
and use that metal Learning System adapt
to this new course with these new
problems and ultimately give feedback on
the remaining
and so in particular what it looked like
is we were able to give a student
program like the program right here and
there's a syntax error in this program
that would make unit tests
um not useful at all and so actually
there were a few thousand cases where
unit tests were helpful but most of the
solutions they were not very useful
um and they were able to actually
generate feedback so in this case the
feedback is that there is kind of a
Minor error on getting the input from
the user which could be something like
forgetting to convert the user input to
a float
um and this system actually worked
really well and it was actually worked
well enough to actually deploy in this
course to give feedback to real students
um which wouldn't have been possible
without some of the ideas that we'll
cover in this course
um so those are two examples the Bingo
model and the education model yeah
you compare the learning outcomes for
the the two groups
um so we did actually do a blind a B
test with the system and so a thousand
of them got human feedback 15 000 got
the feedback from the AI system
um and they the students agreed with the
AI with the metal Learning System
feedback slightly more is like one
percent more I think they agreed with it
around 97 of the time and they agreed
with the human feedback around 96 of the
time
um of course they might just be agreeing
with it because they they like the
feedback or whatever
um and so we actually asked them also
how useful it was and they rated it as
useful a scale of one to five I think
they rated it around an average of 4.6
out of five
um so they found it useful
um we weren't able to measure learning
outcomes between the human feedback and
the the feedback from the system
um because this was towards the end of
the course um it was kind of a
diagnostic at the end of the course
um we also didn't feel like it would
make sense to withhold feedback from
students to compare no feedback in The
Meta Learning System
um
but the I think the real the real win is
trying to
um is basically out trying to give
feedback in scenarios where it was
otherwise would be very difficult to
provide that feedback
I want to be a big difference
yeah so multi-objective learning is uh
we'll cover it in the lecture on
Wednesday
um but it's basically you can think of
it as a subset of of multitask learning
like a special case
yeah are there any applications for
real-time restraining data
timer streaming data
[Music]
um
I guess there's nothing
I can certainly imagine there being
actually a lot of applications making
sense because if you have streaming data
um you may want to adapt very quickly to
the current circumstance that you're in
with a small amount of compute and a
small amount of data so from that
standpoint things like few shot learning
may be very applicable
um but I don't have um I haven't
encountered
there's nothing that comes to mind
immediately in terms of a specific
application I've seen in the lecture
how do we think about these two things
yeah so the question is what's the
difference between future prompting and
few shot learning
um and there is I think there's a very
Gray Line like I think it's I don't
think it's it's black and white
um
we'll we'll talk about this a little bit
in in some of the future lectures
um you can think of yeah we'll talk
about it more in future lectures I think
it's not
it's it's unclear it's fuzzy
yeah because mother learning always
require a model that has previously been
trained on some data because it feels
like now learning is adapting this model
to a new set of smaller data or
um yeah yeah so you're asking does meta
learning always require some previous
data for um or like is my learning just
um essentially adopting a model towards
like you were on your data if that makes
sense yeah so
um kind of transfer learning and meta
learning are in many cases trying to
adapt to new circumstances
um maybe I should I'll move on actually
a little bit because we'll all give kind
of some definitions of what multitask
learning and meta learning and transfer
learning are at least what the problem
statements are and that might answer
your question
awesome
um as a few more example applications of
very recent use cases of multitask
learning and meta learning um
one from 2019 is uh looking at machine
translation uh it turns out if you
instead of translating between just one
pair of languages if you translate
between lots of different languages in
this case 102 languages
you're able to surpass very strong bass
lines that are just trying to train on a
pair of languages
there's a lot of shared structure and a
lot of shared information that you can
leverage from those other data sets or
from data sets of other languages
um and people have also been using uh
multitask Learning Systems actually for
multi-objective optimization where you
have multiple competing objectives
um in a YouTube recommendation system
and thinking about how do we optimize
these objectives
um and we'll actually consider a case
study of this paper in the next lecture
um so these are a little bit more on the
applied side a little bit more on the
research side there's also um I mean
there's lots of papers on these topics
these days and so I'm just highlighting
a few but one example is a paper called
a generalist agent that was training on
like really a really really wide range
of tasks so ranging from dialogue
systems to playing Atari games to
controlling a quadruped robot and
simulation to controlling a real robot
arm
um and so they were able to find that
you could actually stuff the data of all
these different tasks into a single
model to have it do all those different
tasks
um and lastly I guess I showed this
example on one of the earlier slides but
you can also apply this in examples in
real robotics where you want a robot to
take experience from previous tasks or
sorry from previous objects and
ultimately perform a task with a new
object so in this case the robot hadn't
seen this Red Bull before or this Peach
before
um or the distractor objects for that
matter and is able to figure out that it
should
um place the object into the Red Bull in
this case
cool
um so
those are kind of a few modern examples
that are quite interesting yeah
is there any study looking into trying
to understand
controls kind of models like the
Fantastic they train the models before
maybe disentangle them or are they
something that way the function
journalists like kind of a model that is
able to um
understanding of the test performance
yeah so the question is is there work
that tries to understand what these
multitask learning systems are learning
and if they're disentangling the tasks
in some way
in general
because there's no particular paper that
comes to mind and I think that it's also
a very challenging question because we
don't have good tools for interpreting
neural networks and what they're
learning
um I think the biggest tool is actually
just to observe its observe Its Behavior
on new inputs and so for example if it's
able to generalize to new tasks
effectively then that's an indication
that it's not learning the task
completely separately that is actually
learning the shared structure whereas if
it's completely unable to generalize to
that new task it's maybe an indication
that it's not is not learning kind of a
unified representation of those tasks or
that the new task is just too far out of
distribution compared to the previous
tasks
why is it considered what impressive
um so in this case the uh this paper is
from a few years ago but the it
certainly in this case overfitting to
the task of placing I guess I mean
overfitting is is a term that means many
many things oftentimes but you can think
of it as that
um I think what's interesting about it
is it is
um
at least this paper was one of the first
examples of just looking at a raw video
and actually interpreting that raw video
to figure out how to do the task
um and I think that we've also seen
certainly since then seen more kind of
more interesting and more impressive
things being done uh with future
training
yeah
yeah I was just wondering about this one
shot application learning paper because
um like
in general you know that the human
intended to put
um
versus like always putting it in the
bottom left place right like how how
should an AI consider like these
differences yeah so the question is
um it seems like this task is a little
undrefined it's unclear from a single
example whether the goal was to put the
peach exactly right here or if it was to
put it into the Red Bull or or something
like maybe there's other ways to
interpret the video as well
um and the reason it's able to do at
least in this case what at least to me
aligns with human judgment is by looking
by having prior data and so if you only
gave it this one example and learned
from scratch
the problem of inferring the intent is
actually mathematically underdefined in
many different ways
um you could like there's also
especially from images it's especially
under defined because it could be that
you wanted to like change the pixels
here to be orange for example and maybe
that doesn't involve moving the peach
there
um so it's under defined if you learn
from scratch but when you have previous
data and previous experience with other
objects you're able to
um
leverage that previous experience to
figure out what exactly was intended
here so in this case the previous
example involved placing into containers
and in each case it was trained to
generalize the place into the Container
rather than place the object in the same
position and instead if you gave it
previous experience that said if I see a
demo like this then place it in that
exact same position it would instead
learn that from the previous experience
but yeah cool question
okay um and then one other thing that I
think is important in the context of why
we might study these methods now is I
think that it's important for making
methods and deep learning accessible to
many different people
um I mentioned that
deep learning works really well when we
have a large data set and if we take
some of the most common data sets that
are out there like imagenet or these
machine translation data sets and so
forth
they have a lot of data in them uh image
that has 1.2 million images this data
set of English to French translation has
40 million paired sentences and the
switchboard data set has 300 hours of
label data
uh and so this is a lot of data uh and
so if if these are exactly the problems
you care about or the data distributions
you care about you're in great shape
but a lot of problems that we look at
don't have this much this this amount of
data and so for example if you look at
kaggle's diabetic diabetic retinopathy
detection data set this only has 35 000
label data sets uh sorry 35 000 labeled
images
and this is something where deep
learning isn't going to work as well if
you train from scratch on this
um and likewise there's a data set on
trying to adaptively treat epilepsy and
this has less than an hour of data and
one of the papers that I showed before
from the beginning of my PhD where we
were learning the spatula task
this had less than 15 minutes of data
and so this is much much less data in
many applications we don't have tons of
data from or maybe we're we're looking
at a population that has a lot less data
of it
um and I
one thing that one reason why I think
that things like multitask learning and
metal learning is important is if we can
extract prior information about from
other data sets that are larger
um that we might be able to actually
start to better
um better solve tasks that have much
less data
which will in turn make this kind of
Technology accessible to
um to people who don't have the money to
collect a huge data set or don't already
have a data set collected for their
problem
yeah
is there a standard way to quantify how
useful data from one test could detail
learning a new test
your way to quantify
might be useful how how useful it is for
another task
and I guess the short answer is uh
that's an open problem
um it's a really useful and interesting
problem the short answer is it's
unsolved but there is some work on it on
trying to relate the similarity between
two tasks and it's actually not really a
similarity function it's more of a
directional similarity like how useful
is one thing for another thing
um there's also some work just purely on
data evaluation in general like how
valuable is a data point in the context
of a larger data set and so like James
you for example on campus has some work
on that as well
[Music]
yeah absolutely so the question is
um a lot of the examples we've talked
about you have a large data set and a
small data set what if you have lots of
small data sets uh and absolutely we've
seen examples where these kinds of
techniques can be super useful in that
scenario actually in your homework we'll
be working with the Omniglot data set
which has about 20 examples of each
character
um but lots of characters so around 1200
characters or actually more than that um
and so that's an example where these
kinds of systems can work quite well
um and there are other examples as well
where we can sort of like amortize the
the cost of learning
yeah
machine learning models to generate data
stats
[Music]
for example with your blogs I thought
about maybe open pose
um where you can actually get the joints
of the person and maybe that's helpful
for robotics so maybe that that way we
could generate I don't have beta because
I'm sure we have a lot of information
for humans
um so is that something that's
applicable yeah so the question is um
can we generate data sets and is that
useful and applicable in common
um there's a little bit of work on that
so like Phil Isola for example has been
doing research a little bit of research
on that topic
um in general there's possibly kind of a
no free lunch thing where
um
basically if like if you're learning to
generate data from a data set then
you're not really creating additional
information when you train that
generative model and so that might not
be more useful than the original data
that the generative model was trained on
um so from that standpoint
it's a little bit tricky I think to get
value out of that sort of thing but if
you have domain knowledge that you can
put into the generative model that might
help
um
so yeah it's I think it's an interesting
problem and they're actually there have
been a few works that have done kind of
interesting stuff along those lines that
I could talk about in office hours
um like data set distillation for
example
um but in general it's It's Tricky
cool um so I've talked about a few
different successes in a few different
exciting applications of these kinds of
systems but I'd also like to emphasize
that there's also lots of open questions
and challenges and we've seen some of
these in some of the questions like how
do we determine the usefulness of one
data set for another and I think that
also makes it
equally exciting to study because it
means that there's open problems that
that we can solve and that all of you
can solve
um in the last 15 minutes or so I'd like
to dive into
what actually a task is and what
multitask learning is
um and we'll we'll do this fairly
informally in this lecture but more
formally Define things in the next
lecture
so uh informally we can think of a task
um or other a machine learning task as
something that takes as input a data set
and a loss function and tries to produce
a model
I think this is a useful way to think or
a fairly intuitive way to think about a
machine learning task because
when you want a machine Learning System
to solve a task you typically give it a
data set and a loss function and
optimize that to get a model
um and different tasks can vary in a
number of different ways
at a high level or kind of intuitively
you could have different objects
different people different objective
functions which was mentioned different
lighting conditions different words
different languages
um
so the different tasks that you might
throw into a multitask Learning System
might be fairly varied and they could
vary along lots of different axes
um
and so the reason why I bring this up is
that multitask learning doesn't just
cover what you might think of as
different tasks in terms of the English
definition of the word task it could
also mean that
um like typically you don't think of
different objects as different tasks
from the English definition of the word
task but if you want a system that can
handle lots of different objects and you
might want to train it across lots of
different objects
that might still pertain to this more
technical definition of a machine
learning task
um but
as I kind of mentioned this there's one
really critical assumption that comes up
with these kinds of systems
um and the bad news about this
assumption is that the the tasks that
you train on
they need to have some shared structure
if they're completely independent from
one another
then you won't get any benefit from
training together or you won't be able
to get any benefit from trying to
exploit the shared structure
um and if you don't have any shared
structure if they're completely
independent from one another you're
better off just using single test
learning
um the good news though is that there
are many tasks that have shared
structure
um and so as as one example
um if you consider the task of
unscrewing a jar a bottle cap or even
like using a pepper grinder for example
um
using a pepper grinder and opening a
water might seem very different tasks
but they all involve a very similar
motion
um and even if the tasks are seemingly
unrelated
um the laws of physics underlie real
data and so that there is already a lot
of common structure there unless maybe
you're on a different planet or
something and and I mean the laws of
physics won't change there but uh
gravity might change for example
um people are all organisms with
intentions
um the rules of English all underlie all
English language data languages are all
developed for similar purposes so even
across languages there's a lot of shared
structure
um and so on
so
um I think that there are actually very
few cases where some tasks that you come
up with are independent in a statistical
sense and so with that the model can or
these kinds of methods can pick up on
the shared structure and leverage that
in order to do better
cool
um
now Yeah question
let's say language and images
so what is the shared structure in that
house
yeah so the question is um in a model I
got to
it was doing both tasks and not involved
language and images and what is the
shared structure there
um I actually think that in that
particular case the
the gothic paper didn't show significant
signs of being able to
like significant indications that it was
actually learning shared structure
between those two things in terms of
generalization
um and so it's not actually clear to me
that it was learning shared structure
across images and text uh and I could
also imagine that it may be easier for
them all to learn shared structure if
for example you gave it images of text
rather than tokens of text because
uh
those modalities are very different from
one another it's kind of like
um if instead of
well for for us humans we see everything
through the same exact embodiment
through our eyes and and so forth and
we're never like getting uh one hot
vectors of tokens just passed into our
brain
um and that's kind of what neural
networks get uh they don't they don't
um see things in a unified way and so
um yeah the short answer though is that
it's unclear if it was actually learning
structure between the two
um although there is there is um there
is some work that is actually found that
you are able to learn a shared space
um at least a shared embedding space
with images and text
um that is more Unified
lots of questions in the back
yeah so the question is how do you
quantify the amount of sharedness uh the
it's it's difficult to quantify given a
pair of data sets um but one way that's
nice to think about that we'll talk
about in the Bayesian metal learning
lecture is
from the notion of uh kind of Bayesian
graphical models
um if you have two random variables
um if they're independent from one
another then they don't have any shared
structure whereas if there is some
dependency between them um if there's if
there's an edge between them or either
direct Edge or an indirect Edge then
they do have some shared structure
quantifying how much shared structure
they have is hard although conceptually
I think that thinking about it from that
Bayesian standpoint can be useful
yeah
foreign
yeah so if there isn't any shared
structure the model might just basically
learn to like use half the bottle for
one task half the model for another task
um and
uh I guess there isn't there actually
isn't that many downsides to that but
there also aren't any upsights to that
as well
yeah
shared structures are necessary but the
tasks that we're training on have shared
structure or would it also be fine
include the tasks that we're trying to
generalize to is related to
um both of the tasks independently but
the the tasks that we're actually
training on they don't have any like
overlap if that makes sense
can you repeat that yeah
it's true is Task C and that relates to
both A and B in some way but
maybe you're not related but we're
actually training on a and b
um two Journal ones to see I see so if
you have two tasks that are unrelated
and then you want to learn a new task
that's related to both of them
um so for example if you want to like uh
task A's to pick up a fork task B is use
the fork to like skewer something and
then taski is to like to pick up the
fork and ski or something
um
yeah uh the there are certainly
instances where things like that come up
um and and so I would say that well so
yeah yes that's a scenario where these
kinds of techniques make sense
um although
some techniques will be more useful than
others
just like when we
when we belong to the same modality like
text or image or can we have a
combination of protocols yeah so the
question is can you kind of have a
combination of multiple modalities and
in some sense the flamingo model that I
showed before it's actually already
example of a multimodal model that takes
us in but both images and text
um and so yeah the you could have
definitely have gato is another example
where different tasks do have different
data modalities
um if you are representing those
modalities differently than the shared
structure it may be harder for the model
to find the shared structure
um but certainly something that's
possible with these models
cool I'm gonna try to move on a little
bit I think I only have a few more
slides um and then we can take a little
bit more questions at the end
um
cool so um what are some of the problem
definitions that we'll cover in this
course so uh informally we can think of
the multitask learning problem as
learning a set of tasks
and generally trying to learn that set
of tasks more quickly or more
proficiently than learning them
independently
uh and
kind of
here the set of tasks is this we see the
same set of tasks during training and
during testing so we're not trying to
handle a new task
in contrast the transfer learning
problem is we're given data on previous
tasks and our goal is to learn a new
task more quickly or more proficiently
and this is also the problem that meta
learning algorithms also aim to solve
and so basically in this course we'll be
looking at any kind of method that tries
to solve one or both of these problem
statements
now
um one question that came up earlier is
that uh doesn't multitask learning
reduce to single test learning uh so one
thing that you could do is you could
say you have a data set for each task Di
and you have a loss function for each
task Li can you basically sum up your
loss functions combine your data sets to
create a data set at a loss function and
then you have a single task learning
problem where you have one data set and
one loss function
um so are we are we done
um so in some sense uh it can reduce to
a single test learning and aggregating
the data across tasks and learning a
single model is one very viable approach
to multitask learning
um
the
um the transfer learning problem where
you want to learn new tasks is what will
focus on more in this course than
multitask learning because it is a
little bit more challenging and this
solution
um it doesn't just uh reduce a single
test learning but we will have one
lecture on multitask learning on
Wednesday we'll cover other things like
how do we tell the model what tasks we
want to do or what if aggregating the
data set and training on all of it
doesn't work
[Music]
um
so yeah
um we'll focus more on the on the second
problem statement but there is also
still some challenges that come up in um
in the multitask problem statement
Beyond just training a single model with
a single loss function
um cool um so that's it uh I Let's see
we could take a few more questions as a
group but I also
um
maybe we could also just take questions
up in front if people have additional
questions and uh we'll end there as a
couple reminders homework zero is out
and it's due on Monday next week uh and
if you want to work in a group for your
final project we'd encourage you to
start performing project groups